seriously it's true what do you think
Nina oh do you miss trick-or-treating no
no
alright what is up everybody happy
weekend i'm making a second halloween
video if you guys checked out last
week's video was a halloween party at
tds today is actually halloween and we
are on our way I have to go meet Nina
downstairs bra on a way to go pick up
Hayden from his camp and we're going to
go trick-or-treating I have Hayden's
part of Hayden's costume here his staff
and his gloves and some other stuff that
he wasn't able to take the school pick
up and go trick-or-treating yeah
look who I found I found Hayden what are
you dressed up as the crazy gesture we
gotta go get your mask ok ok its Sun
it's sunset sun is setting we got to
quickly eat and then go
trick-or-treating oh yeah we ought to
quickly eat quickly eat so we're gonna
we're gonna head to mcdonalds so junky
such a junkie day made your head to
mcdonalds diva haters gonna get changed
Nina's gonna get some fruit too here we
go what's your message go your favorite
mine is DQ Sunday that's all right ok
thank you sunday Hayden is excited about
the special Halloween Pokemon go huh you
want to see use nearby guys meow and he
learns of motion so hard the crash we're
gonna go catch them what do you think
yeah I'm not gonna catch this pigeon no
stickers i got okay you gotta hustle up
mr. burger first
okay Hayden got his happy meal thank you
Dad Nina has her big mac combo yummy
yummy I really want to know what daddy's
doing daddy didn't get anything that is
not hungry right now we'll see maybe you
leave it it's getting dark can you guys
see outside look sunset happening out
there eat so we can go go go
all right we made it let the pokemon
pokemon let the trick your treat start
him again here's Hayden Hayden what's up
someone died there's graves down here we
can't really see okay go what happened
to the Hat this stuff is making me
fluttering if we just started mr. she
gave me five candy holy cow maybe we
should read some of those good girl what
do you think Nina oh do you miss
trick-or-treating yeah your dress is as
a wife of myself hey yeah but that's
gonna be a costume someday no that's
myself the Nina Carmichael costume is
gonna be a real thing what's that chips
chips oh wow look at that ok let's keep
going wow that's a lot mr. smart they
make you smart i don't know i don't
think so but ok ok good girl pencil you
got a pencil alright that's good let's
go nice educational
did you say thank you that's a scary
house chips yummy I didn't get to see it
I got ya it's okay something yummy oh
okay Oh coffee Chris was yummy all right
let's go this is the best neighborhood
ever to go trick-or-treating in how we
just started to look at much candy icon
I know and you're to give some the Nina
yeah this time I got four candies Elijah
look at that place up there Wow oh damn
yeah oh hey look who's that you say
thank you nina they're giving hot
chocolate here you want hot chocolate
well the last really big now okay you
got me out do you want hot chocolate you
want to go get more candy okay let's go
they have hot chocolate want this side
this house is crazy Wow sure let's keep
going yeah Wow okay it's very angry very
angry okay go next task what yeah very
good Halloween decoration nice that's
nice thing to say Nina's collecting all
the chips if Nina gets hungry we know
where she's gonna start eating yeah
did you say Trick or Treat okay did you
say thank you you see and thank you okay
that's good I look at this place that's
a big spider oh wow look at the jacket
on the roof this place is crazy look at
this spider yeah crazy nice ok go next
house nice nice that was fun
trick-or-treating look how much candy I
ended up and summer in that is bad yeah
extra candy doesn't mean of that listen
I'm gonna eat them tonight what's the
final message of the day of the weekend
for everybody watching final message
from hayden is until next year guys
thank you for watching we believe in you
we hope you continue to believe and
whatever your one word is much love
we'll see you soon hot did la haunted
love we'll see you soon jackpot judge
for ok bye bye have fun guys